hey guys this is Reuben report i'm still
dave rubin you guys know max Luke of
your many time what are we talking six
seven what do you think worse or
something like that six or seven time
guest max lugal yer and I brought in
another David who is dressed exactly
like me we did not coordinate this it's
just our workout David our who is the
co-founder of riot org and you're a
world traveler you've been in pretty
much every disaster area known to man
how do you feel nerve wise to be here
right now oh well I'm freaking out right
now this is a big deal totally freak it
out all right well we got a lot to get
to so let's get to it what's the deal
with white people the owner of rubbing
butts barbecue wants you to know that at
his restaurant jun 11th is white
appreciation day the catch the owner of
the restaurant is hispanic the owner
said we have a whole month for Black
History Month we have a whole month
Ernest panic heritage month so we
thought the least you could do was offer
one data appreciate white Americans with
more than eighty percent of the town's
residents being white customers could be
lining up around the block to get their
discounted pulled pork and brisket the
owner promise is that this is not a joke
having been a victim of racism before in
his own life he hopes the attention will
start a productive discussion about race
okay so the reason I thought this was
interesting was because when I first saw
this on the internet and on Twitter
everybody was going crazy wide
appreciation day like it was some sort
of KKK event or some sort of white
supremacist event right but of course it
turns out that the guy basically this is
sort of a joke and he's just saying look
black people have their monthly t know
people have their month white but we're
going to give them a couple hours no big
deal but the outrage of machine just
gets going when you saw the headlines on
this would you first think well that's
the thing people on the internet only
read the headlines so they see if they
get outraged but I think it's actually
kind of a like a funny cute initiative I
mean you could tell that the guy has a
sense of humor from the name of the
restaurant alone yeah Robin but right
that kind of gave it away from me that
if it was in fact some kind of like
older white racist dude that he would be
awfully ironic yeah if it had been
an older white racist dude would it have
still been okay if he just wanted to do
that and the privacy of his own
restaurant I know we're all over
everybody for baking gay cakes and
flowers and but but would that have been
okay probably not especially like right
in the heels of Baltimore going on at
Ferguson I don't know if it's ever a
good time but certainly not now would be
a good time yeah and what's the point of
these days anyway these appreciation
days are to celebrate minorities right
and with with whites not being a
minority what's the point of doing that
in the first place yes so what do you
make of that because we do have a lot of
that in the country right now I feel
like there's this feeling that white
people feel like they're under attack
which seems to be the reverse of what's
actually going on but in another way it
seems like a human reaction to what that
changing times or something what do we
do about white people like you do hear
this all the time that they that there's
a lot of people that feel like Oh
everything's changing well things
weren't so great for minorities in the
50s so yeah she judges yeah no I mean I
think it's definitely a time where you
know our sort of our sensitivity radars
need to be you know primed and and you
know in sort of you know full operation
but um but this story I just feel like
is it's benign is there some legitimacy
to sort of white people feeling like
things are changing too fast or anything
like that absolutely not I mean come on
the more multicultural we get the faster
the better and I think this is clearly a
PR stunt I think it's working really
well for the guy yeah over the place a
good for him but uh let's not have a
white appreciation day anytime soon yeah
what do you guys think about just the
general state of race which we talk
about a lot on the show we did a story
last week that you know right now in the
country most polls show that white
people and black people feel almost
polar opposite about the state of race
relations it seems to me it's obviously
a lot better than it was 50 years ago
but it seems like we've had this like
sudden slide backwards or is that a
media construct or what do you think I
think that you know obviously we live in
a
he did time for sure with you know
what's going on in the news but but I
think these are conversations that need
to be had and so you know it's important
to recognize our you know the white
privilege that that I think we havin to
go with full sensitivity to recognize
why minorities you know would feel so
outraged yeah that doesn't mean you're
giving up any of your white rights right
exactly yeah you're gonna be okay as
white what do you think about the
general state of race in America right
now yeah that's kind of it's shocking it
sort of it comes in waves right we had
the Rodney King in the 90s and now we're
sort of back to that place where
everything is kicking off and is all of
the stuff's going down and I don't know
why that happens like that it kind of
surges and then it goes away maybe the
media feeds a lot of that too you know
but we could look we clearly have a
problem I mean a lot of these riots are
being instigated by police brutality
which is clearly out of control so we
need to deal with those issues and once
we fix those hopefully we can all get
back to being friends again well said
there's a fitting ending for this one
all right white appreciating day by a
Latino owner at a restaurant for a
couple hours what do you think let us
know in the comments right down below
remember that massive ecological
disaster that nobody talks about anymore
it's been five years since the BP
deepwater horizon oil rig exploded
sending 200 million gallons of oil into
the Gulf of Mexico making it the worst
spill in US history a new report from
the National Wildlife Foundation shows
wildlife in and around the Gulf are
still feeling the effects dolphins are
dying at four times their normal rate
while twelve percent of brown pelicans
and thirty-two percent of laughing goals
have died as a result of the spill the
report also says that this bill has
affected endangered sea turtles red
snappers coral colonies and different
species of fish but these affected
animals are only a small portion of the
13,000 species in the Gulf alright so I
want to do the story because it touches
on two of my favorite topics and things
we talked about here a lot one being the
environment obviously but second sort of
the news cycle and how we ingest news
and how we get outraged by something and
then we forget about it the next day so
David you've been to disasters all over
the world you're
you're living actually living this stuff
not just talking about it like me how do
you think how are we supposed to manage
when this something happens like
actually still paying attention to it
and not just letting it be something
they care about for three days and then
forget about yeah it's a tough cycle I
just got back from Nepal two weeks ago
yeah I was there for the earthquake and
during my time there the media was
really focused on the situation there
and now that I'm back I'm seeing how
we're sort of turning away and looking
at different news stories and that's
natural that that has happened since the
beginning of news that something's hot
for the for a moment and then it goes
away and it's important that we are
reminded of big stories like BP to be
honest I I had forgotten about BPM and
it did happen a long time ago but to see
what's still going on there's magic and
isn't that interesting that five years
ago seems like a long time to us I mean
it's not really and remember for those
how many days was that thing just
spewing oil out to the ocean everyone
kept saying well this is going to be a
hundred year ecological disaster and yet
five years does seem like an incredibly
long time it does yeah and to see what's
going on there now there's clearly a lot
that still needs to be done yeah and so
that's one of the reasons why we founded
riot so that we can continue to
highlight really important stories and
sort of break the new system if you like
yeah just sort of keep going to the next
thing in the next thing and try and
research important stories like that I
mean what can we do I mean you're
someone that's that's sort of involved
in things that riots doing like what can
we do as people that talk about the news
to not forget about this stuff yeah I
mean I think it's like obviously there's
a lot going on in the world so you know
it's not that we're just you know we
have like some sort of like news a DD
but you know like yesterday the news was
all you know Amtrak obviously the
tragedy that happened down there so like
yeah I don't know I think that it's it's
important for media companies like riot
to continue to surface things like this
that require our attention you know I
think that like when you're watching TV
the it bleeds it leads mentality can be
counterproductive to you know a sort of
broader world view but i think you know
thanks to the internet thanks to media
companies that aren't beholden to the TV
broadcast news model i think that they
really have the ability to make a change
and keep these things on our awareness
radar you know
much of it do you think is on us as the
consumers because it seems to me it's
not just like people will say well you
know when there are riots like in
Baltimore they focus only on you know a
cop car that's burning or saying but I
don't think it's that the media is
sitting around having some big
conspiracy about what to show as much as
that's what people watch so like is that
is is it us it's really us that's at
fault as much as the media companies
right I think maybe you do have to cover
something go away but then the important
things to come back and not just leave
it and continually move on and on media
companies need to remember that the
story is ongoing and so maybe turn away
for a little while but come back to the
story and follow up on it so is it not
just the new cycle but it's also Twitter
pretty much like we're so used to just
stuff changing our to our it's like I
mean really Nepal was barely two weeks
ago right I mean it seems already like
we're on and there was just another
earthquake wasn't it was a yesterday or
the day before so it's like this isn't
gone already and yet yeah I mean I think
that's one of the you know most
important questions of our time that we
need to find an answer to like how do we
sift through all the data and all the
information that's out there to find
signal amongst the noise you know I mean
like distraction today I feel like is
obesity of the mind in a sense you know
we've got to look to our to the you know
to media companies and curators like
yourself like what i try to do on
twitter you know to sort of sift through
the sort of debris de to surface real
meaningful content yeah distraction is
obesity matt is that yours make that up
right just right then there it could be
the soup somewhere and it just can't but
I was in the idea of yeah pretty good I
do like that last thought on this do you
think that natural disaster is get the
coverage that they should so you were
just in Nepal as I keep saying so did it
get at least for those first few days
did it get the type of coverage that it
that was warranted yeah absolutely I
mean for the first few days it was just
blanketed everywhere and that's what you
would hope for what's interesting to me
is that we've had a few recently that
have gotten huge coverage but haven't
had the kind of response that we hope
for like the Ebola crisis for example
when that thing was happening it was
everywhere but because Ebola came to the
US shores that was there that was our
focus we
turned inward right we focus very
focused on the guy in Brooklyn who went
bold and we forgot about the real crisis
it was ongoing in Africa yeah so that's
another danger too ya know let's make
sure we remain focused on what the real
issue is and give that the coverage
another good ending remain focused on
the real issues what do you think is is
this the media's fault is just what
people clicked are you still paying
attention to the disasters that happened
five years ago let us know your thoughts
in the comments right down below
happiness isn't just about what
medication you're on it also depends on
where you live the world happiness
report for 2015 is out published by the
sustainable development solutions
network the survey attempts to measure
the happiness of citizens across 158
countries
so a lot of Western countries there I
know countries in the West seem to get a
lot of [ __ ] these days but I guess we're
doing something right in the happiness
Department maybe it's because we're
making countries in the what in the East
unhappy i'm not sure but let's start
with number 15 the united states does
that seem about right to you guys as
Americans do you feel like we're roughly
that seems ballpark yeah we're
moderately not people yeah is there any
chance we could ever be as happy as the
people in Switzerland I mean isn't that
like the thing like they don't get
involved in anything really so and
they're very homogeneous society so it's
like there's a certain level of
happiness that maybe we just can't get
to uh have you thought of that maybe
that's why they're number one and we're
down there towards the end yeah yeah
they don't start any wars they eat a lot
of chocolate so it's chocolate in a war
yeah what else what else would be the
keys chocolate no wars those angry oh
yeah just how beautiful the location is
tearing you know like um I I think
sometimes people need to learn how to be
happy I think it's an important thing
you know like meditation I nose is very
seeing a sort of Renaissance these days
you know i just i think that uh for many
people it's just something that eludes
them because they're just too much you
know caught in a moment and they're not
you know they don't know how to be
mindful and i'm grateful for what they
have right yeah let's throw the image
backup for just a second David what do
you make of the fact that these are
mostly westernized countries so we're
not in all your travels was there some
where you went where you that's not on
this list that you think that the people
might be happier and also of course more
gauge happiness differently yeah so I'm
not a hundred percent sure at the
scientific basis yeah it's interesting
i'd love to know how they gauge this but
i often find that the places i go in the
developing world the people seem happier
and that sounds terrible because we also
we always associate Africa for example
with poverty and there are people living
in extremely difficult conditions but
when you look at people how they live
their in their family unit I often see
people just level of joy being with
always with their family living in
tight-knit communities that's real
happiness as far as I'm concerned I see
it a lot in developing countries so I
don't know how they come up with that
list but if I had to gauge list places
like senegal and
for the people there to me seemed way
happier than Swiss people for example
yeah it's really interesting and I guess
that's the catch-22 of westernized
civilization like we get all these
gadgets right we have all of our iphones
and all that stuff but is any of this
stuff making us any happier do you think
that all this technology that we have
and this interconnectivity do you think
it's making us happy right yeah I don't
think I mean obviously things you can't
buy happiness you know the time that
I've spent abroad in Europe and things
like that I think people tend to spend
their money more on experiences and that
I think is something that not we don't
necessarily appreciate here in the
States yeah much does it all come down
low to what you're saying about like the
family unit i was in el salvador two
years ago it's a true third-world
country I mean they literally don't have
they have garbage that they're burning
on the street because they don't have
trash pickup but the people they're all
did seem relative they were poor but
they did seem pretty happy actually yeah
I think it's a difference between
happiness and joy maybe I don't know how
to define it but there is something
there that we don't experience yeah
maybe its loneliness versus happiness
here we're just we're consumed by our
devices like you said and we sort of
find solace in our iphones and there
it's like you're you're with your
friends all the time you're running
around on the street you're having fun I
don't know but maybe there's a
correlation with the coldness I've
noticed that the top countries are seem
very cold how does that make any sense
I'm not a good guy hence I live in Los
edges but yeah Switzerland Iceland
Denmark Norway Canada Phil yeah they're
all the top of the world very bizarre
bazaar wait where it's so Australia
number 10 Israel Middle East so there
it's warm over there but Wow anyway what
do you think are you happy where are you
watching this right now and does that
make any sense to you let us know in the
comments right down below childhood soon
to not be fun at all it's 10pm do you
know where your kids are experts are
working on a new GPS microchip to
implant and children so parents never
have to stay up late worrying again
although others are well Ian concept
isn't it
see it might not be as far off as you
think using the same technology as the
chips and they're smart keys and credit
cards scientists say you could easily
track your human with ID scanners placed
on doorways counters and street corners
Trish Dickerson a mother of a
three-year-old said I microchip my dog
why couldn't I microchip my son Oh Trish
you microchip your dog why not your son
all right my dog is microchipped I think
that maybe she thinks it's a slight
invasion of her privacy but I think I'm
doing the right thing but to me what's
dangerous about this is just this
endless extension of being watched all
the time between the NSA and it's all
walking around with GPS on our phones
the other day I was doing something on
gmail and something popped up and it was
like can google track your location all
the time which i clicked an eye on I
assume they still do it anyway like to
me it's more about the conditioning that
we're going to have this generation of
people growing up being used to watch or
you know that the government's watching
them they're going to know that and
they're going to be chipped I mean this
is a philip k dick novel in the making
isn't it see i think i mean i don't
think it's a horrible idea because
obviously you know like kids are not
necessarily in control of their
whereabouts you know all the time and
kidnapped all kinds of horrible things
happen but i also think that there's use
for that technology like where that
technology to be developed and to be
ready for prime time I mean there is a
whole subclass of people with cognitive
disabilities that can really benefit
from that people with dementia and
Alzheimer's you know that get lost all
the time yeah so I think that that I
could potentially be useful in them and
they do have something like that like I
think for some patients they have like
your spans or things like that right but
with the wristband I mean then comes the
challenge of having to take it off
charge it make sure that it's like
functional right um so the microchipping
just might be a more seamless way I
don't know right i mean there is the
potential for it to end up in the hands
of people that will misuse the
technology and that's that's where it
gets dangerous right so for example you
could say all right well then we'll put
it in all the kids but we're not going
to turn it on unless there's emergency
but then do you trust the people that
they're not going to turn it on this is
like where the end begins for me yeah
and so what happens I put it in a kid
they track it would is it a pop it back
out or does it stay a nuke that's why I
think the conditioning is
dangerous part because then yeah all
right so they say your parents could say
that it has to be till you're 18 but
then by the time you're 18 or like at
see me I'm not going for the thing and
then just Skynet's part of this and
terminators I mean don't you see that
that's where this is all gone it could
potentially be misused it could you know
open up a wormhole of just you know
misuse and I said I think of that scary
I mean I had to find my friends app on
my iPhone working for a while and I was
like using a steamer my brothers were
but after a while i deactivated because
i thought it was first of all it's
unnecessary yeah but then it could be a
bit of an invasion also is it part of
growing up that you're supposed to be
able to climb out of your bedroom window
and disappear and go to the big city and
your parents not know where you are like
I mean really isn't that an important
piece of growing up like experiencing
what freedom is absolutely uh I mean if
this does happen you're going to have
kids doing the classic bourne identity
thing and taking the ship out so they
can go like hang out with their buddies
you know not have mom spy on them but
you know it's like a black mirror
episode which I've been talking about a
ton on the show I love black mare so
what do we do I mean this every time I
do one of these technology things I
always say well what do we do when this
stuff just keeps coming you know we had
the whole thing with the NSA and then
two months later apple gave us a phone
that literally took your fingerprint you
know you know we just they keep handing
it to us and we keep doing it I'm as
guilty as anybody but what do we do to
manage some of this stuff no it's I mean
there's no easy answer I think that you
know again I think it could be useful in
certain situations so it might be
worthwhile to see where the technology
goes but um but for like every child I
think that's probably not necessary you
know a lot of times people say in the
comments that unlike some technology
alarmist or something or romantic
technology I just think it's important
that we think about these these
questions so how do you think we can
manage sort of knowing that there's good
stuff out of all this of course and most
things that go awry usually intended to
be good at the beginning today I think
it's inevitable because of the
convenience and the life-saving factors
involved with this stuff I'm sure that
one day kids will be implanted with
chips and the government will say that
they're not spying in some future Edward
Snowden will unveil that actually the
government knows everything these kids
have been doing and so right because the
chips are connected to your optic nerve
then they're watching the parrots
through the chips you see what I'm
talking about people anyway what do you
think should we all be chipped is the
game over let us know the comments right
down below as Will Smith said parents
just don't understand how to bathe their
kids Kentucky Child Protective Services
has seized a family's ten children after
they were reportedly found living in
makeshift tents in a tiny cabin on a
garbage jump according to a police
report the family was residing in a tent
the mother had given birth in a tent
there is no running water or septic and
none of the children were enrolled in
school numerous piles of garbage broken
glass and nails were also scattered
about the property as well as a pond
that had no barrier around it to prevent
the children from entering or falling in
the parents are sticking to their guns
about their alternative lifestyle saying
the authorities are punishing them for
embracing a free-range approach to
parenting which gives children total
independence from infancy the couple has
created a GoFundMe page which has
amassed more than thirty thousand
dollars in donations alright so I'm very
conflicted about this story we just did
a segment a second ago about
microchipping kids and what that can
lead to and then you see instances like
this where they're doing this free-range
parenting thing I'm not a huge fan of
government overreach I'm a libertarian
in many ways so I don't like the
government getting involved in forcing
everyone to do everything however if
these kids were you know around a pond
that was dangerous and there was broken
glass and they're not being bathed and
there's other health issues okay I get
it is there a happy balance between
basically being this family and being
the microchip freaks yeah i mean i don't
think that they're doing it right you
know i think that when you hear things
like broken glass around like that's
just I don't think there's any excuse
you know it seems like they're almost
doing it for attention you were saying
right before like yeah I my I'm not on
their side I think that the fact that
we're now looking at this issue I think
it's because i love the government and
you want the government about every
decision in everyone know well like but
it doesn't seem like the kids are it
doesn't seem like it's a safe
environment for them you know alright so
now we obviously don't know every
specific about this family in one of the
pictures at least on the go fund me page
they look pretty put together and then
we saw some stuff where it looked like
they were literally like
in dirt or Hooper's um where do you
follow that like how involved the
government should be in you know making
sure people are doing the right things
with their kids I'm with Max on the
broken glass that seemed sketchy to me
but what I have kids I want them to look
like those kids with dirt on their face
I want my kids to be living in the soil
yeah parenting life not living some
synthetic clothes you know in clothes
life when I heard the section on the on
the report there that talked about how
the ponds didn't have an enclosure
around it that made my blood boil a
little bit yeah because I mean come on
there is a certain limit we have to let
kids roam free it's at a certain point
so this family has got it right to some
extent but you're right broken glass
adverse poverty the kids could probably
be leaving a little better than that
yeah but you know you see people you
know families in the developing world
living in tensile that I'm a defined I'm
not you know there's no judgment passed
but like this particular family isn't in
a network of other families that are
doing that and you know a system hasn't
emerged they're just kind of like it
seems like they're winging it it's not
safe it's not clean this desire for
people to get off the grid I do respect
the the idea that's going on here that
they want their kids as you're saying
they want them to grow up with something
a little bit different and not be
staring at the phones all the time at
every black mirror episode and all that
so I respect all that stuff and yet at
the same point something seems off here
where how do you draw the line of where
someone should get involved is its
health basically yeah well I mean at
least let's look at how we treat this
time position of the situation of the
developing world they have to have
certain minimum standards by which we
can we can call that a healthy family
the kids have to have access to the
proper amount of nutrition proper access
to health care certain levels of
education if they're doing all of those
things to whatever minimum requirement
we have set for them in whatever state
they live then beyond that let them do
whatever they want do you guys think the
off-the-grid movement is like the next
big thing that more and more people are
trying to do this yeah I think like
companies like tesla are definitely like
facilitating that so I think I mean I
definitely think it's a positive thing
for society and you know truth be told
those kids are probably pretty healthy
because they're you know they're they
were probably born naturally they were
probably your they're playing in the
dirt you know
longest healthy you know microbiomes or
immune systems are probably better than
your average person born in a sterile
environment via c-section they probably
know a lot more about survival than the
average four-year-old right that
anything more generally yeah so I'm not
hating it's just when you read things
about like the broken glass that it's
happening on a garbage dump you know
that's where my radar goes off just
don't raise your kids in a garbage dump
and then besides that do what you got to
do anyway what do you think let us know
in the comments right down below nobody
wants to see super Mario's nose hair or
do they video games are about to look
even more realistic thanks to separable
subsurface scattering or SSSs for short
designed specifically to be used for
virtual characters with human skin ssss
renders in real time meaning that it's
not just to beautify cutting or
cinematic interest instead it's a real
time gameplay although this technology
is not yet available in games currently
on the shelf the project has the
official support of activism and will be
implemented in games in the near future
alright so I'm fascinated by the story
because I used to be a major video game
player I don't want to brag guys but I
used to be an assistant manager at
Electronics Boutique you may know that
is gamestop nobody sold more Pokemon
than me at 99 I'd walk true story so
what gets me about this is it seems to
be like when I I can still play like
8-bit Nintendo or Sega Genesis and I
still love it it reminds me of childhood
are saying when I try to play games on
ps3 or xbox 9 or whatever it is it's see
it all seems too real to me is that am I
just old and grumpy no you're I mean
you're describing what people refer to
as the uncanny valley paradox where
there's like this sort of u-shaped curve
where when we get to a certain point of
realism if it's not real enough it
starts to be revolt you know repulsive
to us but I think that this is really
amazing technology the fact that
technology can now render that level of
realism and realty and to me is just
incredible so is that scary because we
all saw and I had the same reaction when
we saw that face in the package like
that look real that look really real
does that seem scary to you somehow I
think it's going to be scary when they
start to apply it to like the gore like
first person killing games when you're
like killing real people who knows
that could encourage yeah but I do think
you're kind of an old man trying to
repress the advancement of pixilation
and keep it back in the 80s if I can get
everything to still be a bit I ready I
would be absolutely thrilled so all
right so I know that some people will
make the argument that you're saying
that you know there's always this idea
that video games cause violence even
though from everything I've seen there's
no scientific proof that it's true but
that eventually will start there's a
difference between playing you know doom
or something from 1994 and shooting a
lot of pixelated stuff to literally
shooting things that look like humans so
and then you throw in some you no
prescription medication and it's a bad
combo right yeah no it's definitely I
mean it's scary but I tend to look at
the bright side of things this
technology might bring us one step
closer to our own personal Ava from ex
machina who I'm completely in love with
this week it was amazing grab a movie so
I think that word just get we're one
step closer to that you seem obviously
you want to bang you want to bang a
robot being scenario yeah well you're
ignoring the question you want to bang a
robot yes or no I mean the shoes really
sexy you bang a robot yeah no coma bang
a robot but no no do you want to bang a
robot let us know in the comments right
now but I've been warning you people
that the internet is killing us these
days are go to doctor is a search engine
according to science daily researchers
found that only three of the top ten
results from symptom-based google
searches were useful for self diagnosis
a researcher told sciencedaily if you
had searched for the symptoms of
something like a bad head cold you could
end up thinking you had something far
more serious like an issue with the
brain this is kind of a problem
considering google reported about 20 of
its 100 billion searches every month was
for health-related information
I love this story because I think we all
do this have you guys done this you know
you have anything you have a headache
you immediately think you have cancer or
some other yeah yeah it's not good to I
mean it's good to you know just to
inform yourself in general but if you're
actually on well you should go see a
physician so this is one of the catch-22
there's been a lot of catch-22 s in the
show today but like of the internet and
of Technology and all this stuff but we
have access to all this information but
we don't really know what to do it they
do we absolutely not and everyone can be
a publisher and everyone is a publisher
and there's so many differing opinions
so when I have a headache I'll google it
and a freak out the first time something
oh great i have a brain tumor and so
what I'll do then is look for another
differing opinion that tells me I don't
have a brain tumor right that's the
biggest problem because I can convince
myself that I'm not sick when maybe I am
it's causing a brain to examine too much
time working out all this stuff yeah go
ahead yeah i just i think that the
internet is not yet at the point where
you can make an accurate diagnosis over
it i mean there's no question about that
but i do think the internet is amazing
for the fact that information is now
free and we can learn more about our
health and our own biology than ever
before in a previous time and so to me I
think that's amazing i regularly am
googling like weird health things you
know which I which I really enjoy so
right so what's the last weirdest tell
thing that you my god that you convinced
yourself you had I assume that I
convinced myself ahead you know I don't
I am obsessed with brain health and
nutrition stuff so i think that like the
fact that a lot of these studies are out
there is incredible i mean before the
internet like you would either have to
go to a library but chances are
libraries don't have the most up-to-date
medical journals so to me I just I think
it's incredible the world that we now
live in yeah how do you guys know who to
trust I mean that's yeah I always say
when it comes to news like I don't know
who to trust anymore I feel like
everyone has some partisan agenda
everybody's owned by somebody it's
extremely hard to pick a news
organization you trust so what we're
talking about health it's that much more
dangerous like yeah webmd I mean that's
pretty much I guess where everyone goes
I don't know who owns webmd or what
their connections are with
pharmaceutical industries wrong how do
you decide like what site you go to and
how do you trust that I think Google
decides because it's whatever pops I'm
turn us right yeah so I don't know how
scary that is Web MD seems to be the
first one that pops up but then there's
like lib straw
so you have Lance Armstrong Foundation
and we know he's totally on the open up
right we there on anything later he's
totally cool yeah hi I tend to think the
PE I what I do is I look for
peer-reviewed journals I start with the
abstracts and then if you're able to
find like the full study most people to
know this but you can actually go to the
references the citation section of those
studies yeah and they just lead to a
Pandora's box of just like insight and
information that you can track
infinitely down the rabbit hole and and
to me it's really really awesome but I
feel like you did much better in school
that I did I did pretty good I did do
pretty good but like your your [ __ ] was
much more research than my I was really
interested in science and computer
science in high school but I didn't end
up going back a Democrat I ended up
studying psychology and film the
human-machine to me as always has always
been an endless source of wonder and
fascination that's another good quote
your honor quotes today so you mentioned
this before about the brain tumor thing
but have you ever convinced yourself
that you really had something well I got
back from Liberia last year I did four
trips to Liberia are working for Riot
yeah and when I came back was freaking
out that I may have a bola so it's
constantly searching symptoms of Ebola
yeah the same page over and over again
trying to reassure myself that I don't
yeah and so at least at that time it
worked for me call me down so it did cut
it did come you didn't come and did you
have any of the symptoms that could the
symptoms were sort of flu like right
there wasn't something that we wasn't
like you know people thought it was
gonna like blood shooting out of your
eyes yeah well the problem is when
you've been somewhere where they have a
bola you get the slightest headache and
you freaked out yeah you know I'm a
hypochondriac anyway but you got a
headache and I'm like oh my gosh
symptoms of all it's like first one
headache and did you just say you're a
hypochondriac your hypochondria and you
went to Liberia absolutely well what is
that that there's got to be some sort of
psychological condition probably google
it all right what do you guys think are
you diagnosing yourselves with major
psychological or physiological disease
right now let us know in the comments
right down the road all right that is
the big show we will do it again next
week max where can the good people find
you Twitter max Luger and I've also
started youtubing building a my own
YouTube channel so I you know max lugal
you're on YouTube I like how you laughed
through that you know we're
tpo yeah I know I know that but I've got
such a tiny little YouTube channel but
i'm working on a pro yet like you well
I'm just humbled to be you know I'm only
40 million subscribers behind Bieber so
you know David dark mark and the good
people find the online follow us at
right muse Ryo team yuud's and check
this out every story let you take action
there you go alright thanks for watching
guys and we'll see you next week